hello it's me everyone doing is that all
this year's you like to be if you think
you'll never say a roll up roll up or
not Erna I look I'm gonna oh yeah my car
you're amazing just the way you are
elected this a long time
follow me on all the songs and
prosody and saying that means a all
Fineman I'm sorry
oh nana what's my name ooh na na what's
my name is a rear we go ooh a Bandhan
and then I got and then and then I know
isn't that Rod Stewart was it was it
right was it sound - I don't know
friendly DJ I had no idea um darling
done no no no no no wasn't watching
every solo now ain't good enough
no big bow but it starts out to go so at
least we stole the show there we go
all the old people man I don't know my
god laughter and a
[Music]